your kids are how old now 11 and 13 oh
wow I know it it happens best yeah it's
very fast
yes it's well it's 11 in 13 years yeah
yeah exactly 11 in 13 years we know
exactly how long it felt just a little
longer but not really that the 13
happened first though it did yeah the 13
came first like I would say around two
years yeah that sounds about right
yeah I can't I can't I can't you don't
don't quote me yeah yeah it's hard to
remember something you could make a
phone call right after we're out of here
and clear this up yeah we'll run the
numbers sure later are your kids like
are they excited at all when you tell
them oh I'm off to work yeah like for
example go tape a television talk show
like this well I don't want to say when
specifically well but let's say you were
to mention hey I'm off to tape Conan do
they even know what that is
you know what they do and for whatever
reason whenever I do your show no other
talk show but your show they get super
excited and give me a list of products
that they would like me to mention wait
is that true it's 100% what happened
because one time I came on the air and
talked about something I saw on Shark
Tank and we got this giant box of this
one product and so they're just like
okay listen and they every single toy I
like that we're the magic conduit they
think that this is a portal the Conan
show is a portal to this world of free
stuff right that's right this is the
thing in Star Trek where things just
beam up and you have products right do
they really are they really excited that
you're here today
yeah totally they wrote they wrote down
a series of products they want me to
mention yeah do you want to hear right
okay there is a couple of these things I
don't know what they are there are a
couple that I do iPad pro of course it's
my daughter
and then she also wants dog nail polish
I didn't even know that was a thing yeah
I think it's just nail polish yeah dog
that dog doesn't code no they also don't
do their own name no they don't
oh boy boy that be a dog Wow
listen what a dog tonight yeah yeah a
lot of money on that yep my son wants
Alienware what I don't know Xbox
minecraft is that what that's I know
those are two separate no that's Xbox
minecraft but he already has that I
don't know what that's about
wait yes specifically a server called
hypixel I I'm a thousand years old all
of a sudden that's a turret I mean first
of all I think you're gonna get some of
that yeah you're not gonna get an iPad
pro that's not happiness
that's no no you don't give stuffin
they're not giving that out if you were
on Ellen you'd get that that's not you
guys that's for just walking in them
yeah yeah as coasters in there I think
you have a good chance of getting the
dog nail polish yeah I think you're
right I think you're a very good chance
I think someone
all right